Hi Data 2100 students, as we
get going into the semester, I
wanted to make sure that you had
an introduction to workbooks.
Workbooks are a great way to have
additional practice with all of
the skills and techniques that
you're learning in this class. So we
have developed these workbooks,
but what you can think of them is
just tons and tons of practice
problems and practice that you can
access at any time. So the practice
problems include answers as
well. So I'm going to go ahead and
navigate over into our workbooks.
So we look here at workbooks.
Here are the workbook files.
This is linked. If you go to
module 0 in the home page of
canvas you will see workbook files
linked. So go there to module
0 and you will find the workbooks
linked in that module 0.
So when you take a look at this
you can see here that there's SQL
Workbook Files, Flowchart Workbook
Files, Python Workbook Files, and
Data Analysis Workbook Files.
We're going to start here with SQL
Workbook Files. We update these all
of the time. You can notice that we
have our Overland ERD dictionary
linked here. And then you also can
see here that we have the SQL
Workbook Overland linked as well. So
if you take a look at that you can
see here that for each of these you
have all of the questions okay
so here's all sorts of different
query prompts that you can dealing
all dealing with overland that you
can practice over and over and
over again then if you want to test
out hey am i doing these correctly
you can click on the overland answers
and the overland answers will
pop up and then you can see all
right what am i doing correct and
not correctly so you can compare your
answers that you did that you got
based upon just looking at the
questions to the actual answers
that we have here for you this is a
great way to learn to practice do
your very best and then come to the
answers and see what am i understanding
or not understanding and then
of course always feel free to
reach out to us with questions. But
you have these for each of the
different major components here of
the class, so make sure that you use
them. Reach out with questions if
you have them, and that's an
introduction to workbooks. Take care.